let's read the news let's read this Rick
and Morty season four why our fans
threatening to boycott Rick and Morty
we'll see already they're wrong because
true fans love Rick and Morty oh yeah
they're neither [ __ ]
well right that's the point the headline
is wrong fans are threatening hold on
where's your source media yeah twitter
twitter huh yeah the Karen's on Twitter
is that that was my assumption I'm not I
have a feeling like correct we got this
story we got this story oh man all over
the place it's all the same thing let me
read it independent Rick and Morty fans
threatened a boycott show over 9/11 and
Pearl Harbor jokes
one viewer accused the jokes of adding
fuel to the xenophobia of Islam on geo
here's another one
furious Rick and Morty fans threatened a
boycott show over controversial 9/11
joke
hold on no they don't I got this ready
okay boomer yeah there you go
they're not even it's the perfect time
well who's upset about that then dude
well I'm a millennial and I I do not
care yeah some boomers get listen Rick
and Morty it's great yeah goodbye your
bro well actually I think I think they
are but they're loud yes I think that's
you've got look Gen Xers mostly don't
care boomers mostly don't care ya got a
lot of Carin boomers though yeah they
really it's Millennials man they care
enough for everyone yeah Millennials and
some of Gen Z yeah look at this Rick and
Morty fans took to Twitter in a rage
they said they would boycott the
animated show due to its use of 911 and
Pearl Harbor jokes others more know The
Daily Star
Rick and Morty fans boycott show no they
don't you see how they went from
threatened to boycott - they have
boycotted it ya know this is the toilet
cycle of fake news yep it begins it's
spinning around they're all playing a
game of telephone okay spoiler alert for
those that haven't seen the new episodes
of Rick and Morty I haven't I'm going to
ruining it for me they're gonna tell you
the joke and you are going to laugh and
when I explained you the context you
will laugh even harder okay because
we're adults that and understand what
jokes are there even people you know who
have made really offensive jokes I think
who was it oh it was Ellen she said
something about
that she feels she knows what it feel
what it feels like to be in prison oh
yeah because she everyone's on the same
Club oh she's wear the same clothes and
everyone's gay yeah and I was like I
have no problem with her making that
joke yeah I thought it was a stupid joke
right no Roman said you thought it was
really funny
I'm like I didn't I thought it was it's
kind of funny I did I mean I was like
yeah you know I mean no I don't care I
don't think she should be shut down our
band for it all right I think Jimmy
Kimmel has awful jokes do so just even
Gobert
so does all of them Conan's okay but
he's still you know I like him more than
the rest of them I like Conan he's funny
which is on that show that Cody's just
eat traveling around yeah but he's
really stupid things like us he has he
went to Haiti and was like look how
awesome it is and it's like that is
extremely reckless because it is not
look man there's all of these young
women there doing the solo female
traveling okay and they're making all
these videos with her like look at me I
went to Syria like I kid you not one one
chick went to Syria okay it's like dude
like you do not want to she'd do that
move - yeah yeah she's like she's like
she's like this and in the photo and the
thumbnail and it's like solo female
travel in Syria like a bunch of blown
out buildings behind her - yeah how do
you do that I'm not gonna build oh so
nugget much Damascus in his mind blown
out buildings but she did go I'm pretty
sure she went to Aleppo and and listen
man look I got no beef you want to go
travel the world do all that stuff
that's fine okay but if you don't
explain the dangers of things and the
problem in Conan was like things are
great here in Haiti and it's like whoa
whoa whoa bro like I have I have done
security consulting for people traveling
to dangerous places yeah and it's not
appropriate to dance around and act like
the parts of these world parts of the
world are completely totally fine yeah
if you're good if you're gonna take a
photo of you chillin at a resort in
Haiti I'm gonna need to provide the
context to people like make sure when
you come here you've got your your not
your proper vaccinations yeah you have
your contacts you know the embassy knows
like he probably had a big crew with
them too it's not like oh let's get back
to Rick in more yeah so here's here's
the story
fans of the hit animation Rick and Morty
have threatened to boycott the series
over its inclusion of controversial
jokes with the bombing of Pearl Harbor
9/11 that of all the things they could
have been offended by these the least
like if at least said white privilege or
something I'd be like home during a new
episode of the series called
promo
primordius the characters Rick and Morty
are are seen flying towards to
skyscraper towers in a clear reference
to 911 after swerving to avoid them Rick
quips honestly I'm proud of us for not
so totally would have been cheap replies
Morty Rick then says Pearl Harbour on
the other hand before flying towards an
alien harbour and bombing it oh it was
very funny later in the episode the
characters banter about the incident
with Beth Rick's daughter asking so you
did a 911 and Maury replies almost in a
911 we we went with a Pearl Harbor we
were pretty classy fans have taken a
Twitter to voice their discomfort with
the jokes is Rick and Morty still doing
911 jokes asked one viewer adding
because wow that's so funny in 2020 yeah
it gets funnier with time that's the
point of like oh I just imagine like
there's a bunch of like I don't know our
age anyone it doesn't matter who likes
Rick and Morty watching it and the moms
like walking down the hallway and like
what was that joke what I wait go back
go back let me hear that again no it's
not the boomers man I don't nobody knows
the Millennial IG w's no I'll tell you
what happened I'll tell you what
happened the sjw's are sitting in their
offices at the independent is other
other companies right and and and
they're like while it's locked down so
there's like ooh this is a good clue no
they're sitting in a room and the guys
got I think yes a guy's got one of those
cylinders Salette cylindrical cages the
use for bingo were you like oh yeah you
can write anything and there's a bunch
of things bobbing around and the Spanish
Flav's playing in the background while
they're all like laying there hot in the
summer heat and you and the guys just
like lazily trying this thing and then
stopping he goes and he goes okay
everybody today's outrages shuffles end
it goes
Rick and Morty 9/11 jokes and I gotta
start writing everybody's angry
others picked up on a different aspect
of the joke with one commenter writing
everyone's reacting to the 9/11 joke
personally I was fine with it until Rick
said ask the Saudis just adding fuel to
the xenophobia of Islam and the Middle
East when you could have easily made a
George Bush or US government joke he did
that before to another fan wrote
boycotting Rick and Morty this is such
fake fake news the number one post on
the Rick and Morty subreddit is no no we
don't Rick & Morty fans threaten boycott
and they late to the independent says no
we don't and they really really don't
know do you know you know what it is
it's they're getting paid to look for
this kind of stuff so it's not that they
even care they're not boycotting it
they're looking for any way to make an
article probably it clicks that because
they get paid for that and now we're in
the time we're like we need any any way
to get clicks this will work
they probably write the tweets
themselves yeah I'll stop short of
directly accusing any individual but I
wouldn't be surprised if they're using
sock puppet Twitter accounts to be like
Oh Rick and Morty is offensive because
of 9/11 you know the 9/11 are you
kidding me you think the people who
watch the show are funded by that there
was a joke in the pickle pickle wreck
episode where he turns episode he turns
himself no pickle and then Morty walks
in he's like morning I'm a pickle and
and Morty's like okay is is that all and
then Rick goes what I turned myself into
a pickle wouldn't me to say I turned
myself into a pickle and 9/11 was an
inside job it's like it's hilarious
there's also a joke
where in the episode where they're in
Rick's memory okay when they're trying
to extract the the the portal gun
trying to figure it out he's like he's
like I store this memory between you
know I camera but it was he was like the
morning of 9/11 and when you know I had
like ice cream or something
and then as they're leaving you hear
very faintly in the background he's you
see him in the background by the TV goes
oh they're gonna use us to take away our
freedoms and it was like it was funny Oh
Arnie Joe's I like it so basically in
the show they're on this um it's like an
Astra it's almost a planet whatever
there's a alien civilization and because
they're Rick and Morty they're like
wreaking havoc and just blowing
everything up and they're laughing and
they're
this is really really great and Rick's
like I just needed to bluff some steam
and they're blowing people up and he's
like man it's like it's like popping
bubble wrap and then all sudden they
start flying up and there's two towers
and they both look at each other like oh
and then they swerve out of the way and
that's where the joke comes in where
they're like yeah you know I wouldn't
feel good about that one and then they
look down and there's a harbor and it's
like well I could do a Pearl Harbor
though and I think it was hilarious yeah
it was a great episode
the last episode the latest one was
really weird but I enjoyed it
nonetheless no but this is what we get
from the media they they I think I think
we it this is all a culmination of
things we've been talking about mm-hmm
nothing's happening yeah exactly no
board it's like what's the news new Rick
and Morty news yes we can complain about
it yeah oh and then you know it's funny
we're sitting here going oh oh look
they're pretending to be outraged about
Rick and Morty we can complain about it
we're doing the same thing this is the I
feel like we're winning here though it's
well it's it's a big that I've talked
about quite a bit where it's like are we
just as bad for engaging in the same
bickering by calling them out for doing
it or do they need to be called out for
doing it I think the latter I personally
think they need to be called out for
doing it yeah you know you like great
it's it's you know the like I mentioned
I would love to see a world know fake
news I'm just sitting on a couch eating
nachos like yeah nothing to do it's like
the last any one of these fans they're
talking about it's like okay what
happens in season season 2 episode 3 go
and they'll be like I don't know I
actually had never seen Rick and Morty
yeah I don't know what season twitch I
can't off my head tell you bout season
Jim yeah no I'm just going a few really
extreme there but if you made a
reference to a bunch of episodes I'd be
like oh yeah that episode I mean it's
funny you know it's crazy like let's
let's do this I want to pull it the the
legendary count dank EULA yes yeah I
don't know if that makes him a lord like
a being a count like sure
yeah what is it count let me Google that
as far as I'm concerned and like you
it's pretty good he's a noble status my
liege he has a noble status in the
culture war he tweeted this 60s to the
80s conservative Christian boomers
cancelling comedy 90s to the 2000s
absolute Golden Age
where everything was allowed tens and
twenties social justice creatures
cancelling comedy so we've gone full
circle that's that's that's that's what
it is man he's right yep exactly no you
know you're not I was thinking hmm
there's a bit there was a big wave of
like edgy anti-semitic comedy because
ironic mocking of like Judaism and
Jewish people sure and I was wondering
like it was popping up all over you know
YouTube and stuff there's a there saying
recently in the past few years
cuz you say that I just think like Mel
Brooks oh he hit up on everybody
basically yeah yeah yeah but there there
was a video G teen comedy we were
watching a video recently I think it was
I think it was like a Adventure Time
compilation of Lemongrab okay so that's
also voiced by Justin roiland who it did
Rick and Morty and then like I was
showing you something about Lemongrab I
was like you got to see this you know
this I got to give you the context and
also and randomly Adolf Hitler popped up
yeah because people do that to be edgy
you think it's funny to be like I'm
offending you by doing this yeah okay
just randomly injecting this kind of
stuff and there's a period where people
were doing this really really edgy
comedy there's like you know the cast
Annie flag is mm-hmm it's Pakistan and
I'm sure I'm not gonna get the perfect
context to explain it but it's a
fictitious country okay and the flag is
a it's a parody of the like that what
like the German Nazi flag or whatever
swastika I just pulled it up is yeah
it's the green and it's got like the
4chan leaves on it kak or whatever okay
so it was like ironic Nazism was like
meant to be edgy okay
I was wondering like what happened like
why did all's and everybody think this
was a funny thing to do it's really
really obvious to I think to piss off
the other people get pissed off South
Park South Park when I was a little kid
what did I hear non-stop on Comedy
Central
Cartman's screaming about the Jews okay
seriously like non-stop even to this day
it's like it's just like a huge aspect
of the show because Kyle is Jewish we
were talking about it before the show
but there's one one episode where Kyle
is like about to die in a flood and he's
and he's like Cartman help me in
Cartman's like quick but first throw me
the goal that's around your neck and
Kyle's like what and Cartman says I know
every Jew has this or something and then
Kyle was like Cartman you know that's
not true
and then cows Cartman refuses then
finally Kyle pulls a bag off his neck
he's like
here and it gives the gold to Cartman
and then Carmen goes aha but I know you
secretly carry a fake bag of gold and
then he throws it give me the real one
and Kyle goes ah and then he pulls
another one that's like it's it's it's a
joke yeah we know that Jewish people
don't or don't do this it's meant to be
you know silly and absurd but then you
also have a Family Guy
okay another show that was like it's
just been popular forever yeah they go
nuts on on Mort you have it like they
have done endless jokes and so you get a
bunch of kids who grow up seeing that as
comedy and they laugh about it you know
and they embrace it so looking at Count
de Aquila's tweet where he says 90s to
thousands you know absolute Golden Age
or anything was allowed
yes South Park went nuts yeah I mean I'm
not saying in a bad way I'm like it was
funny we grew up watching this stuff we
were like not a you know we're not
offended and now today you have people
emulating a lot of these things they
grew up watching thinking it's funny and
also pushing the boundary and now we're
getting the moralistic sjw's harrumphing
like you know it's really funny about
these people
mm-hmm the one that one of the things
they pointed out was that when Rick
mentioned the Saudis it was like
xenophobia it like kicked it over the
edge do you think any of those people
care about 9/11 no that's insane
like if you told me a feminist sjw was
complaining about the horrors of 9/11
I'd be like shut off it's not true and
it's literally what they're doing
basically and no Rick and Morty fan
cares no it's a funny show it is a
good--nice episodes kind of way I really
enjoy it yeah but you know you know
you're not I will I will add to this to
two scary things that I think are
happening right now
one is in desperation with there being
no news we're gonna see a whole bunch of
fake stuff like this yeah cancel Rick
and Morty or cut it like shut up dude no
way like a bunch of people show up to
McDonald's because I wanted Szechuan
sauce when the episode came out about
that border line riots people like
screaming give us sauce like Rick and
Morty episode about it yeah yeah and
then McDonald's did like a very limited
run where they only had a little bit oh
man
and I but people showed up demanding it
I'm like you think these people are
gonna boycott the show though the people
complained us how aren't fans well the
other thing is we're getting close to
election season mmm and now we're gonna
see astroturfing like crazy and man
I hope you guys are ready for a wild
wild ride man
I am I'm ready you know aspirins ready
go ahead and lighten me so it's when
they when they set up fake protests okay
so it was typically a reference to like
hiring protesters okay and now it's it's
it's a very very vague and broad like if
you pay for a protest you've astroturfed
I don't agree with that so like if you
pay for a bus so that a bunch of people
from one area can go purchase another
and they call it astroturfing okay what
kind of it you typically when I heard it
used you know ten years ago it was when
corporations were literally hiring
people and paying them to go stand in a
field and they didn't even care with
politics so it looked like people cared
yeah if a bunch of people want to
protest and you say I can help you guys
out
yeah no sir but I get it it is
borderline like you're creating the
circumstances where they can do this
well and if you're the one paying them
and you're gonna benefit like you know
if they're if your direct opponent if
they're they want to come because they
don't like your direct opponent then you
bring them over that's like yeah you
know it's right in the line I guess
right yeah so that's why I think it's
necessarily unfair to say astroturf hang
in there context it's very nuanced yeah
yeah but then there's sock puppet tree
which is look man I'll tell you what you
go on reddit I be willing to bet 80% of
the comments you see fake fake yeah
totally fake like go on reddit there's a
bunch of surprise I'm not gonna get
specific but it man it's crazy when it
when a news story broke you used to be
able to go on Reddit and it would be
number one all it would you know like Oh
a power plant exploded and you'd go and
there would be like upvoted not anymore
no no nope nope nope now it's almost
never broken sjw's it's all anti-trump I
mean I kid you not notice I was I was I
go on our /all which is just every
subreddit ranked by their votes okay and
I was looking at as if it was our slash
pics it's the it's the the picture
subreddit where it just shows you
pictures of things okay and it was
anti-trump and I was like why I don't
care man you know they complained about
the Donald because like one of the
biggest it
right yeah it's where it's actually one
of the most prolific meaning generators
okay so that MIT Technology Review did a
study and found the Donald and 4chan
were the most prolific creators of memes
that went viral around the internet okay
people used to complain they were like
it's not through because the Donald
posts row is on the front page so they
eventually made him change the algorithm
to suppress the Donald and now it's
nothing but anti Trump trash so this is
what I'd say I hope you're ready for a
wild ride because stories like this are
gonna get nuts you're gonna see
astroturf bang you're gonna see sock
puppet Reeb rig AIDS I'm like like
reddit is is a dead zone as far as I'm
concerned that's feels like so some
people argue to me saying it's you can
still use it okay just go find your sub
right like go to the Magic the Gathering
so I'll read it yeah you know that the
only time I ever really used reddit was
like an L F G site for destiny looking
for groups like destiny one right long
time ago yeah we have you so you would
go into the so frozen are familiar when
you want to play with this game destiny
and you need people to play with you
yeah you would go on to the right but yo
who wants to do this and like here's my
username company you know add me yeah
yeah we just make those posts that's how
we would find what we would find good
crews to go do stuff I think the whole
thing oh yeah you were playing destiny
with me at the time where yes yes that's
a good times yeah good old days man six
years ago the vault of glass oh man yeah
Oh G days that's a good go G destiny one
man read it now you go to the front page
and it's like there's there's somebody
called murdered by words and it used to
be like sassy comebacks mmm now it's
just people complaining about Donald
Trump what that's all so I bring herself
up for one I love complaining about
reddit because it's just like the it's
it's this websites been totally
destroyed its you know world politics
one of the biggest social media forums
in the world
1.2 million users smile went so far to
the left they started posting
rule-breaking anti-trump posts and
people were just like what's happening
yeah so then eventually they said well
if there's no rules and instead it just
became porn that's what happens whatever
yeah if there's no rules it start
getting crazier and crazier and then
just completely collapsed so I think I
think we might see that depending on how
much stress is put on say Twitter
or read as a whole okay if the people
running these platforms keep doing this
that what they're doing is imagine
you've got like you know a bamboo pole
and so you start pulling it to the left
and you're pulling it harder and harder
and harder eventually it's gonna break
yeah and that's what happened with world
politics I think it's possible that you
know Facebook Twitter reddit all these
sites as a whole are pulling so hard
it's gonna break yeah but it's not just
the companies doing it one of the
problems is there's I'm gonna avoid
naming them but there's some
high-profile companies that hire people
to manipulate on social media hmm
notably for the Democrats I'm sure the
Republicans have a but the Democrats a
big company got caught doing this it's
not really surprising so here's what
they do is you'll you'll go into a sub
you'll see a post that's not political
and they'll come in and they'll make it
political of course in the comments
they'll inundate it and they'll you know
jam it up well let's say you make a
comment where you're like you know I
don't know how I feel about Donald Trump
okay then they use a bunch of fake
accounts to downvote you so that you're
gone so the only ones you see are orange
man bet great so what happens the
regular person as they come in and the
only thing they see is everyone hating
Donald Trump and so I guess the goal is
to make people believe that everybody
hates Trump so so I bring it up in this
context because this story is for the
most part just desperation in my opinion
right so yeah that's what it feels like
but I agree but I think it's gonna get
absolutely nuts thanks for checking out
this clip from the Tim cast IRL podcast
we do the show live Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to catch
the full show tune into this channel
subscribe hit the like button or check
us out on iTunes and Spotify and we will
soon have this podcast up for free on
all podcast platforms thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all in the next
episode
you